one of the last things I did live was a
show here at Largo with like Sandler and
Apatow and oh and it was so much fun and
I think a couple of days later
everything shut down it's crazy yeah
literally the date the day things were
shutting down I did Who Wants to Be a
Millionaire I got to like be a
contestant and it was the most exciting
day of my life and then we like went
back home and everything was shut down
we couldn't tell anyone it was like the
weirdest most dystopic feeling yeah yeah
did you win anything I won $500,000 for
charity charity yeah oh I would love do
you want to know the question that I
that I would actually want to quiz you
on this because I thought you would know
the answer to this go ahead okay this
was the question that I had to get to
get the $500,000 and I had to call my
dad as my lifeline and he helped me but
okay six US presidents share the same
first name John James George William
which there are six presidents that have
that one name it's not William can I
hear him again John James George William
Wow George Washington George Bush man
that's a really good question it's
really hard I don't know anything about
president so I was like totally yeah I
do I just know that there's a lot of
George's and then there's James Madison
James Polk James man now you you're just
want to go no I want you to guess it
okay I can I write these down George I'm
eliminating William George and I think
I'm wise to do that hello correct you're
correct George James and what's the
other one
George James John James John F Kennedy
there's James Garfield it's a lot of J
there's James Polk there's if you want a
hint yeah there's like a nickname
associated with one of the names that
also makes like there are more
presidency
a nickname as well well yeah because I
think it's gonna be James because big
that's why I just think it has to be
James because it can be Jimmy
it could be James it could be Jim yeah
so that's what it is that's correct but
it was so tense my dad I called my dad
and he said John and then we were just
sitting there for like ten seconds and I
was like are you sure and then he was
like James James James and I could hung
up on him and then I had to sit there
for 10 minutes and weigh whether or not
I trust my dad like it was just like
crazy you know what I wish I wish I had
been on that show and I wish I had
answered that correctly I think I would
have answered that correctly and then I
wish that I had won and I've been really
excited and then I wish that on camera
they had reminded me that the money goes
to charity and I wish everyone could
have seen my face fall and then me start
to kind of ask like well yes I imagine
some goes to Charlie and then see me
getting into it with the executive
producers as the credits come down